in Exodus 6:3 when God said to Abraham I
appeared when God said Abraham Isaac and
Jacob as El shouldi but by my name I was
not known to them know to them yes
because um I think in previous
Revelations to this men they actually
knew him they actually knew him as
Jehovah in previous Revelations what's
previous Revelations the only Revelation
you have is the Books of Moses and
that's part of Exodus Exodus is part of
that Revelation it's Genesis Exodus
Leviticus Numbers Deuteronomy oh no I
mean in um when God revealed himself to
Abraham in that oh you mean previous
Revelations you mean when the Lord had
appeared to the Patriarchs okay because
sometimes you're confusing me brother so
you're saying in the scriptures like
specifically Genesis when God reveals
himself to Abraham Isaac and Jacob the
name yah Jehovah's used yes yes so
you're trying to figure out what is
Exodus 62 three mean exactly that's it
let me show people what he's saying now
guys if you engage each other in the
comment section you're not going to
learn you're here you want to learn you
got to focus will make it funny but
entertaining and educational do not
engage people because that means you're
not going to learn you're wasting your
time please listen it's a class even
when we're having Q&A because from their
questions you're going to learn the
depth of scripture because watch this
objection if you're not listening you
won't hear what he's asking me in Exodus
6 2:3
Exodus 6
2:3 here's what we're told God spoke
further to Moses and said to him I am
Yahweh yahwah I'm using Legacy Standard
Bible and I appeared to Abraham Isaac
and Jacob as God Almighty when I
appeared to them I made myself known as
El Shai but by my name Yahweh I was not
known to
them so here he's asking me here God
says I didn't reveal my name Yahweh to
them all right but then you have Genesis
22:24 just to name one place Genesis
22:14 and Abraham knows the
name Abraham knows the name exactly if
you're not listening you're not going to
learn how to address these alleged
contradictions Genesis
22:14 and Abraham called the name of
that place Yahweh will provide but I
thought he didn't know that
name I thought
he didn't know that name so if you guys
are busy debating each other go start
your channel because you got to learn
you're here to
learn and Abraham called the name of
that place Yahweh will provide as it is
said this day in the Mount of Yahweh it
will be provided so how do we we answer
this question if God says to Moses by my
name Yahweh I did not make myself known
to them I made myself known to them as
elai God Almighty and yet here we have
have Abraham
Abraham using the Divine name Yahweh
will provide yahwah Y is there a
contradiction so this is what he wants
to know so now that you're listening and
not engaging each other so you can learn
and may the Lord bless the numbers for
his glory and save me from error there's
one of two ways you can address this the
simple way because the other way is the
way this is the actually the view I take
but it's complicated one of two okay
okay one of two ways okay what you're
reading in Genesis
22:14 is Moses writing down by
inspiration of the Holy
Spirit what the patriarch said but in
recording their statements he will now
use the name known to his audience so if
Abraham had
said the place will be called the Lord
will provide and he used
Adonai Adonai
Moses will come and say Yahweh why
because he's writing after the fact and
he is recording what Abraham said but
he's going to use the name of God now
revealed to
them
ah and that's actually what you find in
the New Testament what do what do I mean
in the New Testament written in Greek
when they quote the Old Testament that
has the name Yahweh they don't use the
word Yahweh they use the word Lord
kuse okay so you see what they're doing
they're doing something similar to what
Moses may have done now when they're
writing what was said right or what was
written in the Old Testament where the
name Yahweh appears in the New Testament
they don't use Yahweh they use the word
Kus
Lord can I give you example what I mean
yes please do you know you are you need
you want a lot of
attention my bad no it's my bad sir I'm
G to give you
are you ready yes sir all right are you
laughing at me or with me I'm with you
well I Gotta Laugh first see I caught
you all right here okay Deuteronomy 64
watch here Deuteronomy
64 yep exactly Baghdad instead of stapon
whicher karti condemned Jay Smith for
here Exodus 6 there Deuteronomy 6:4 here
o Israel Yahweh is our God Yahweh is one
so the Hebrew has the word Yahweh right
yes but now when
Mark writes
down Jesus's speech because when Jesus
asks what's the greatest commandment and
Mark writes it down in Greek look at
what he says same
passage okay Jesus answered the foremost
is here Israel the Lord our God is one
Lord doesn't use yah Mark uses the Greek
word for Lord Kus
right so you see what he's doing
yes okay so Mark is taking the name
Yahweh and substituting it with the word
Kus Lord so it's possible AB Moses doing
the same thing that when Abraham is
saying let's say he's speaking Hebrew
and he says
Adonai Adonai Lord will provide he will
then record that as
Yahweh right
now let me give you another example from
the New Testament right so that's a
simple explanation I don't need to go
any further to complicate things but
here's another one Psalm 110 verse one
are you guys learning Psalm 110 verse
one are you seeing how it works your
Bible if you're not listening you won't
see how the Bible has been produced and
composed by the spirit working through
these human authors and you won't get
the depth and richness of the Bible and
how beautiful its structure is so listen
learn don't engage it's not social time
it's Bible learning all right here
another example Psalm 110 verse one
here's another example Psalm 110 verse
one now watch this is an accurate
translation of the Hebrew in that it
doesn't say the Lord said to my Lord it
says Yahweh said to my Lord in the
Hebrew if you were reading Hebrew it say
Nom yah
the utterance of Yahweh to my lord it's
two different words it's not the Lord
said to my lord it's Yahweh said to my
Lord that's what Hebrews said sit at my
right hand until I put your enemies as a
foots for your feet but then when Jesus
quotes it and Mark writes down Jesus's
words in Greek because Mark is writing
in Greek look at how he writes it down
you see it he's now recording what Jesus
says about this verse this is Mark Mark
12:36 David himself said in the Holy
Spirit the Lord said to my Lord he
doesn't use the word Yahweh he uses the
word Kus Kus or kuras
Lord uh I see I see what you mean h so
here when Mark writes down the words of
Jesus in Greek the word he uses for
Yahweh is Kus or some will pronounce it
kuras Kus okay
Lord so he didn't use Yahweh but the
text that Jesus was quoting it uses
Yahweh here let me show it to you see
how the Bible Works Yahweh said to my
Lord
yahwah not trying to impress you I'm
just trying to show you what the Hebrew
would say but then in Greek he doesn't
say that in Greek
it's Kus said to my Kus the Lord said to
my Lord so you see how Mark
replaced substituted the word Yahweh
with kirus
Lord yes yes I can I can see that I can
see that did Moses do something similar
that when Abraham would have said Adonai
Adon Adon he then comes back and
replaces that with Yahweh because that's
the name they know him by right right
possibly so that should suffice yes yes
it does actually because at first I was
thinking that the name just like you
taught us you know by listening to all
that you say and your um by reading your
articles um it felt like when God uses
the name in the Bible it has to do with
some revelation of
himself yeah but God reveals more of
himself throughout Generations right yes
yes yeah